what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
fourth episode of the Mandalorian of
course joined by John of course joined
by MJ tesler our Star Wars nerd ladies
and gentlemen you know what to do use
the force to leave a like this is the
way also of course you catch our
full-length ratchet watch Longs over at
our patreon along with a bunch of other
stuff but yeah just looking at this
image you're getting ready to watch this
I'm just thinking about what it must be
like for Pedro Pascal to take care of
that sexy beard underneath that helmet
well we have just a thing to maintain
that sexy facial groom thanks to our
sponsor manscaped the leaders in the
below the waist grooming AKA your crotch
region now have beard products along
with their enhanced brand new weed
whacker 2.0 but seriously stick around
because after this ad you're going to
want to use our code Rejects at
manscape.com to get 20 off plus free
shipping so guys there are a few Brands
we partner with whose products I
continue to use regularly and manscaped
is one of them yeah so use all those I'm
a married man I keep my balls in good
condition for the misses so if you're
married and or single or you just want
to look good when you look down south
landscaped is the one for you but most
of us see each other's faces before we
see the nether regions am I right
hopefully you guys don't do weird things
on social media so they have the brand
new beard hedger Pro kit John you're
looking reasonably hairy yeah oh my God
you look so much better now you look so
awful before we look great now that is
what a man looks like I sit back in your
chair all right so that was just with
the razor but not with the actual
extension you're like what is it is
there only one clip no this is one of
the reasons why I love this electric
beard hedger because it's not only high
quality but as opposed to most trimmers
where you got like 45 different
extension clips you get a sort through
it's all in one do I mean by this
actually
it's tough on the hair but smooth on the
face and I fullheartedly agree and they
also got this weed whacker 2.0 with
improved blades and no tugging guarantee
I did a full sweep last night but John I
see what's going on there oh my god dude
this is this what is wrong with your
nose Jesus trying to get so much [__]
nose hair get back in your chair the
beard trimmer procreate also comes with
a beard shampoo and conditioner beard
oil and beard bomb to moisture style and
Shimmer your new beard the kit also has
three free gifts beard brush comb and
scissors baby and for the classic
manscape Thrills they now have the
performance package 4.0 which does
include the weed whacker 2.0 and all the
other lower region products John Let's
shave your balls a lot of people ask me
beg me constantly harass me Greg what is
one of the best ways to support the
channel one of the best ways to support
the channel is by taking care of
yourself by going to manscape.com using
our code rejects to get yourself 20 off
plus free shipping once again that's
manscape.com our code rejects 20 off
plus free shipping ladies and gentlemen
this is the way
to looking and feeling more confident I
tied it into the Mandalorian good segue
let's roll that in
oh yeah and a friendly reminder koi John
and I are going to be having a panel at
WonderCon Sunday March 26th 11 o'clock
a.m so if you're at WonderCon please
come and say hi because it's going to be
a fun time
you are redeemed and Bo Katan Crees you
too are redeemed what the [__] cares go
back to Pershing
oh wow
wow that's a wallpaper
ah
wow I like how they practice with the
real weapons yeah like any real
Mandalorian should
[Music]
once the train is foundling
wait are those rocks sentient or is
that's a snail okay
put down the Rocks kid it's time that
you learn with the other foundlings
playtime's over you're not a Jedi you're
meta Warrior next Challenger
Dan just passes in the dark saber
he is too small I'm his Ward proceed
he your ward Greg is technically older
why doesn't he wear a helmet he is too
young to speak the Creed and so too
young to wear a helmet
then he's too young to fight
they explain why he doesn't wear a
helmet I like that one does not speak
unless one knows well I know
perhaps this lesson is for you then yeah
you little [__]
that was so cute my dad was the same way
he's just proud of you
oh
you take it easy on him kid
go for the jugular each has three darts
you may fire the darts in any order
Mandalorian squeeze your fist to launch
the darts
you'll be fine
press triangle to launch the Darkness
ready
again
mess this kid up brogu
h
I've seen what you can do
it's okay
show them forced joke the kid
it's gonna stop at midair
again yes no
[Laughter]
winner
there you go
it's like an 80s group yep
[Music]
all right
whoa what was with these creatures
everywhere
no glasses it'll kill the child I mean
the child is like
it must have been at least mangled by
that
it's pretty cool yeah game of Mandos
oh man
nice
I'm out of fuel
it always gets away oh you should have
shot the dragon with your blaster
so that's a smart move
magnificent Dragon heart yeah oh great
movie I will go get him the mountains
are too high if we use jet packs the
Beast will hear God you never offer a
solution Vizsla we must avoid explosives
and Blasters for the safety of the
foundling
this is the plan
are we moving along quickly come
you wish to become a Mandalore
and they make of a montage to begin
[Laughter]
be the puppeteer
what's she giving him a little best car
earmuffs this is the forge just as we
shape the Mandalorian steel we shape
ourselves
oh he's going through the first episode
of dinjarin in this series
oh my we refine ourselves through trials
and adversity
it's going through a wave of emotions
yeah I should have stayed with Luke
yes review weaknesses
buddy
what is this episode
oh flashbacks
oh oh
my God it's expanded
the elevator
oh my goodness
everything's gonna be all right kid whoa
holy [__] we're doing this awesome
there you go
nicely done
oh this guy's awesome
[Music]
oh wow
oh my God
awesome
great perspective shot
nice
oh my God
oh of course
hey
[Music]
nice reference
looks like a Naboo ship Keller in back
wait I'm at best I'm pretty sure that's
Jar Jar Binks oh
[__] there are no others
oh shh
filled and ready to go come on
[Music]
wow this is relentless
[__]
oh my gosh
[Music]
punch it are they not hitting like
traffic
no
stay here
keep expanding the lore expand the
trauma
my blood pressure
Mandalorian steel shall keep you safe
you will grow into this rondelle as you
grow into your station
foundling grogu oh founding grogu
it looks heavy as hell yeah
[Music]
iced out we'll continue on foot from
here
any closer and it will hear the ship
I also hear vizzles complaining
yak yak yak the whole way the target is
on the top of this peak if we tuck in
under this outcropping we sleep out of
line of sight and climb at first light
look at her leading
like Starship Troopers it is exactly
what it is when you get your food you go
off to find a place where you can take
off your helmet
what a hassle I mean it really does bye
everybody
maybe it helps you appreciate your food
you are the leader of the war party
you have the honor of staying by the
[__] oh [__] oh there's some not great
blood there between those families
my hair must be crazy no no wow it's
literally perfect I thought her face
would be smushed
one with the best
oh yeah
aesthetically this is freaking awesome
look how cool this is I mean this is 13
year old Michael's
this is what I did with my action
figures
once we could just take off our helmets
that's [__] up I can't see [__] out
of this
I should
have kind of feel like we're in A Bug's
Life right now yeah a giant bird
I would love the bird just snatch them
all up right now
oh boy oh that hell little helmet there
you are no longer a Mandalorian yeah
get your helmet off while you're being
eaten let's find the kid
kids oh it's pretty safe for the babies
wait until we clear the air Children of
the Dragons he's my son oh baby Vizsla
oh
whoa there it is
oh boy
it's pretty awesome
[Music]
oh
that was a great shot
this is a vindictive Raptor
oh
geez oh Pete dude this is crazy oh
oh my God
[Music]
way to go hang on
that's a Boba Fett
Return of the Jedi right there
this is great
this is a beautiful sequence
shoes
directed this episode Jeff Goldblum
well Jurassic Park
are you okay
this is the way
so when you have children when you're
making the child do you keep your helmet
on yep and your socks your best car
sucks
make sure you use best guard protection
as well
foreign
[Music]
s in need of care and training
it's gonna be hard to forward [__] for
them oh but they're going to be great to
ride
you're in need of a repair
come with me
I inlay the Signet of the night owl
the metal saw belongs to all
mandalorians it is always acceptable to
wear
I would like that
this is getting real interesting she's
plotted man
get me one of those what would you say
if I told you I saw one
it is a noble vision
no I mean a real one
when you choose to walk the way of the
Mandalore you will see many things but
it was real
this is the way
I don't think you're comprehending the
information in this context that's not
enough
what the hell and written wow
wait I'm at best I thought it was I'm
pretty sure that's Jar Jar Binks oh
yeah
for a minute I was like is it
isn't all that they wouldn't they can't
be that crazy they must that's
incredible yes and and his Jedi
character is is from the the Disney Plus
game show the Jedi Temple Training
Academy show
damn way to piece that together thank
you some sleuthing
what a return to the franchise
I know that was epic should have
recognized that earlier my bad now I'll
have to throw it into the reaction
weirdly I can throw it in the reaction
I'm throwing it I gotta edit this you
son of a [__]
Greg if if I called it and it wasn't him
that would have made me a horrifically
race
you're racist you're a faith that you
would edit out any races
absolutely now if this part is going to
end up in the video
but not the actual part let the records
I want the record to show I was the one
I cut out what he said when John said is
that Mace Windu and I'm like no that's a
different actor I completely cut that
out and when I corrected myself and said
no it's Lawrence Fishburne Doug yeah
yeah that was jar jar Biggs and then we
dropped in a super cut of every time
you've ever named a black Act
all right let's talk about this all
right that was a whirlwind of an episode
people that was a that was a wild ride
that was a Non-Stop let's just slam our
foot on the gas pedal yep yep yep
because the the episode that Carl
Weathers directed last season had much
more of a deliberate build and then it
had this great Chase sequence it was an
awesome Chase sequence and I kind of
flashed to it when they are uh going
through Coruscant here so I was like
some of these visual motifs but who
knows that Star Wars it could be any
other director maybe I should have
called it should have said it out loud I
take pride when I guess directors
properly but anyway regardless I still
thought this was a really fun ride like
to me pacing wise it's similar along the
lines of the first episode of this
season but there was while I wish at in
the beginning parts that it you know
what I want to say I wish it breathed
better because in the immediate in the
immediate moment I was like I could I
could use this episode kind of slowing
down a little bit but when I really
think about it I'm glad we got to the
good [__] faster it was actually quite
satisfied that we got there much faster
because yeah it was a little bit weird
at first but as we kept going I thought
it was a very entertaining episode with
continuing this flashback that we saw
for people who don't know that is in
book of Boba Fett season two when you
saw the beginning parts of that
flashback and I like how they started
off from where you left off and then
they're just sort of like panning and
you're like oh [__] we going further
into this flashback now and then to get
everyone's favorite character Keller and
back back in Action because his name's
pulled up there that's how I remembered
it from the top of the Jedi training
academy uh competition show on Disney
plus I'm obsessed with that show which I
totally knew what that was what an
extraordinary repurposing of Jar Jar
Binks uh yeah that is Canon the Jar Jar
Binks right that's Jar Jar Binks that's
I mean he turns into Jar Jar Binks is
what you're getting well we always do
everything was working on he was being
able to turn
that's what you're trying to say right
this is the dark side is jar jar who we
know is the real Sith Lord behind the
Clone Wars yes yeah and then Keller in
fact is the chosen one uh no it was it
was so
I love these flashback sequences and I
feel like they've been doing so
I mean like it just captured the magic
of the of the prequels uh yeah it was
like the pr it was like the attack of
the Clones Chase sequence but more
purposeful and much more intensity due
to the situation of Order 66 going down
at the time yeah and and there's just
nothing quite like watching clone
Slaughter jet I don't know what it just
does something for me uh but
but no it I mean little nerdy
observation so that was I mean
definitively looked like uh uh Naboo uh
star Cruiser
um that Kroger's put on that that he's
put on and those I mean they were
literally wearing they're literally
wearing the clothes here yeah so
um I mean I'm I'm curious what that
implies and where where that means grogu
goes Dale Organa protected grogu
probably and then the question is
and also why didn't they just leave them
with Yoda if that was the case but
anyway these are questions Roku wasn't
created until the mandelion came out no
this was George Lucas
yeah that's why it's all in a cocktail
napkin yeah
what'd you think man I really enjoyed it
I think I'm gonna be I think I'll pick
up the football from you and I'm gonna
make this very disjointed let's go for
it I had a blast with this episode uh as
an experience I I will say mostly in a
good way like throughout this episode
there were things where I was like wow I
want to keep spending time in in this
thing and this thing and this thing and
so like yeah I really like this Felt
Like A Slice of Life action scene to me
this episode because yeah you have that
sort of major beat with grogu having
this sort of PTSD moment and and I I
really like the flavors of that scene
and and the like weird emotion National
aspect where it seems like yeah this is
you're watching somebody pound you know
an innocuous piece of Steel but at the
same time you know it does have this
sort of dark harsh you're in a cave and
there's fire and I can see how you would
sort of find yourself going back to a
traumatic place like that really
interesting stuff and then the other
side of the episode is this yeah finding
the halfling uh that's a motif that they
use in like this whole show is it
finding the halfling finding the the
films
throw everyone off their game today
let's keep it going but yeah this was an
episode where like I uh them climbing
the the side of the the rock face was
beautiful I would watch an episode where
like that's most of it dude no seriously
if you did one of those like survival
like were just in the elements and we're
just trapped on the side of this
mountain the only thing we could do is
get to the top Bears Mandalorian yeah
like yeah I'm with you um yeah like the
journey was really fun I uh I did kind
of genuinely get caught up to the point
where when we got back to finding the
kid I was like oh that's right that's
that's where this episode started I
think the thing for me uh is that uh
this was the only one I liked a lot of
the visual language of this episode but
this was the the one so far that felt
the most uh like the the effects were
effects a lot of the time so it was like
the I thought the ending uh battle I
think they put it all into that ending
uh fight with the uh Raptors
um yeah there were moments where I would
get pulled out being like oh this looks
like like what people criticized the
Robert Rodriguez directed episodes of
Boba Fett for being it's kind of what's
started to look like like oh it's a
bunch of dudes on a beach and like
Mandalorian cosplay which still looks
good which is still kind of always
what's happening yeah um but yeah there
was like a missing like layer of that
you know movie Magic Sheen but other
than that I thought it was really fun
you feel like it it kind of reminds me
of like an 11 year old like in their
basement playing like yeah totally I
mean it's so sporadic the pacing is so
weird and I'm I'm loving it in in like a
like the cinephile in me like if there
was if this was anything else I'm not
sure I could go along for that ride uh
do you feel like
coming from from your film perspective
oh yes like as a Doctrine I have a
Doctrine in films do you it's an
honorary doctor who had six years at
state school for that film doctor six
years yeah wow yeah that's incredible
um well tell me then Sean with your film
doctor uh did you
I'm so excited this question the answer
is yes by the way I did very much so in
fact
as George Lucas would say did it rhyme
ah it felt like one of those poems where
it's just kind of compiled of a few
different ideas and they kind of slapped
them together in a way that like kind of
sounds associative and neat didn't
necessarily seem like it was really
bound thematically as much as it was
like by the elements which I think is
cool which I think is neat yeah I think
what we needed was to kind of give a
[__] about the foundling being taken
that was a part of it that was like this
is going way too quick and then we're
like okay I guess we're doing this whole
grogu story right now
there's a raptor tracking and it didn't
feel like those and then the wave was
going to The Flash and I was like what
the hell is going on right now I'd say
like oh he's going through a traumatic
yeah so we're about to send it to a
nightmare because it just kept going
between have you
happier yeah no the the direction for
the puppeteering on that was a little
like what's going what's going on but we
don't get to choose when we have mental
breakdowns and I feel like think really
capture the spirit of that they did
that's what they were going for that was
that's what Carl weather said to them
someone was like this is playing a
little strange she's like we don't get
to choose
I I do think that the kid too like there
was almost it didn't feel like there was
much jeopardy with the Raptors because
the kid was like absolutely fine he got
like spit out of the mouth of the thing
and he was like not wet no blood like
there's one rip on his shirt and that's
pretty much it Boba Fett survived the
sarlacc head and I'm just at the point
now where like it's anything and it's I
mean this is like clone wars and bad
this episode rang a lot like a clone
wars and bad batch episode that's true a
child would be swallowed and then spat
out by a dragon in Clone Wars I mean the
whole story with the with the Raptor
dragon is about as cliche as it gets
with getting up there
baby yeah yeah no you're I mean it was
literally A Bug's Life uh yeah
yeah I mean I think that's
this does feel the most like a kid just
throwing toys together wrote it well
it's it's in a in a way I appreciate it
what happens when you like leave Dave
filoni a several million dollar budget
like it was bound to happen and like
John Favreau is not exactly the adult in
the room either so yeah he's I want my
character to have more of a character
Arc this time
now that filoni's a little busy with
Ahsoka fizzle's gonna have a kid I want
to be able to have a food truck I'm
gonna have a lot more dialogue this time
this is the way Dave oh man no I mean
it's it's it's something that only Star
Wars uh in a franchise like this can get
away with
um but it's I mean it's fun because we
can be a little bit older and enjoy it
and I feel like for people that like
this is their new entry in the Star Wars
this is the kind of stuff that made me
fall in love with Star Wars when I was a
kid so
um no it's it's top tier really fun
what's going on with Bo Katan bogutan
um okatan Chris Bogota Han Solo Han Solo
Razz Al ghoul
my first Batman to it uh yeah I
I feel like she's
they PL you know what the biggest
giveaway is they played this almost
Sinister it's like an ominous music but
sometimes the border is on Sinister
whenever it's cutting to her in these
kind of scenes and especially when it
was when it came to the mythosaur like
she's got some devious plan a person
even though she was kind of fighting and
telling the worst person to tell that
like if you're conniving that was the
bad but then again but the armor was
like she's lost like three times now
yeah like maybe not the best political
strategist in the in the bunch well
nobody can read in each other anybody's
facial expression it's true oh you just
have the helmets and the lighting to go
off of so anything could be in this way
yeah well I I think that she wants I
feel like her saying that and then the
fact that the armorer herself
themselves I don't know the Armor's
pronouns but whatever the armorer is the
way the armor is reacting is like yeah
it's just a vision she's like [__]
please yeah you know so I think we all
seen a myth disorder but I know but Boca
tank could tell that everyone answers to
her so I think Bo is gonna try to get
the mythosars to prove and then and then
writing that thing out we'll take her
leader that's the thing I mean she
doesn't even really need to I don't
think that she's necessarily stepping on
the Armor's toes as much as we
originally anticipated in that regard or
as you know one is the head of state
one's the head of the church you know
and it all kind of it all works out no I
think I think she's gonna have a dark
turn I think she's gonna try to take
over
I think that she could have that and it
can all be fine and they can live
happily ever after because mandalorians
really they're conflict diverse I feel
like they really don't like violence and
end fighting uh no I I'm completely
there with you so I think that I think
too
sorry this is my this is the review
where I'm just interrupting both of you
Non-Stop uh this is what I want to do
just interrupt sure got a real thought
and just call attention to the fact I'm
interrupting yeah that makes for a more
interesting video sure yeah and these
things behind it why is Greg interacting
what's the face
guess why I'm interrupting you get to
continue your original point I think we
would have rather than saving the fact
that that was vizsla's kid for some
reveal I think that would have
immediately made the journey way more
interesting
yeah if we just instead of trying to
make a reveal out of it if we just
learned it like right away yeah that's
my son and then you're like okay now
it's a personal investment in getting
this kid back yeah it also would have
made the little like Roku kicking the
kids butt a little bit more enjoyable
for this like weird view that exists
between uh visla and punish the kid
could I yeah can I ask you guys a very
important question sure how do you kill
her and back yeah yeah how do you feel
about uh Yodas and grogu's flipping and
fighting I mean but they try to do that
I think um an animated form it's awesome
sure yeah I think yes I think there is a
reason that attack of the Clones decided
it was time to retire puppet Yoda sure
I look I love it and listen I mean I
love very funny
but I love it so long as like grogu
doesn't have to like like quickly walk
away from like a really emotional scene
because that's the problem is I can't
not laugh every time oh it's hilarious
like like if if they were like the
funeral pyre of like a character that we
loved and grogu needed to walk away from
that that would become a that would
become a problem but to my point that
was rudely interrupted earlier but I
respectfully interrupted earlier by Greg
um so something that Dave filoni and
John Favre have talked about a lot and
that I've really been trying to pay
attention to this season is
in in the spirit of George Lucas they're
trying to borrow a lot from like real
history real like lore and a lot of like
spiritual you know right like when the
dragons abducted the Jews
so well it's funny you say that because
bogoton is a Hebrew name okay and then
bogoton's father was named Adonai and
the story of people who were exiled from
their Homeland had to like wander
through the desert like all I'm saying
is
Ark of the Covenant discovered by
Indiana Jones from the crash Millennium
Falcon it's all it's all connected one
big universe I understand yeah well guys
what did you think about this episode
were you jazzed about Keller and Beck is
this going to make you watch that show
the Jedi Temple Training Academy I'm
very excited for him I'm happy yeah me
too I mean like if you hear a story
that's like that was a badass fight no I
mean in a double lightsaber like yeah
and to go from like the most most
loathed character in Star Wars and like
he like really suffered from depression
and and subtle thoughts and uh like to
come back and in this kind of way
um I love that the Star Wars Community
is has given him this second chance dude
if anyone knows the Star Wars Community
they are very nice people all around
[Music]
are very passionate and and because the
community's so nice
I am intentionally throwing in the part
where you notice Keller and back in the
credits
vid to you know because all those
positive comments are going to come in
if you don't throw that in right at that
moment yeah of being like
hey we understand you didn't immediately
recognize him at first but that's
actually the guy I played Georgia that's
how people are going to say it
it won't be people being like how did
you not recognize him you call him a
Star Wars nerd that is not the voice of
the Star Wars community no no listen
call me out do it that makes me better
see that's that's what I love about
something
we're always learning
Twitter it's not like Irene it's not
like I read every single comment
multiple times per day we're talking so
much about your stuff and if you had
stopped interrupting me during the video
you would have gotten your points out
faster do you think that if Dave filoni
removes his cowboy hat he has to bathe
beneath the Living Waters of lucasfilm
in order
yes they have a Yoda Fountain there I
bet he has the bathe in the Yoda
fountain
guys
leave your thoughts down below we're
gonna be a WonderCon all right come down
say hey 11AM Sunday
hey I think John really wants to do a
patreon
Brandon Benzie Brandon Benzie you have a
great Mandalorian name house Benzie and
you know your first name is Brandon but
you would be the first Brandon in the
Galaxy which would be a huge honor you
could get your name emblazoned upon a
shoulder Signet Crest thing and you know
never remove your helmet and then when
people walk by you they'll be like oh
man there goes Brynn and Benzie the the
Mandalorian friend to you and me is it
is it like Han and Han Brandon and
Brayden
that's a typo on the list
great on Benzie isn't even more that's
like a dupe Star Wars
that is your new you you're reborn we
are bathing you in the Living Waters
beneath the patreon and now you are
braid on Benzie for the rest of the year
2023 in the name of our Lord mandalord
in the name of the dark saber and of my
helmet and if this is the way
and of mythosaurus
thanks for Don
foreign